[موسيقى]
تفعل
لذلك
تزوجنا [موسيقى] في عام 2019 ، حصلنا على
حفل زفاف مدني في جورجيا
وبعد ذلك افتتحنا وكالة زفاف خاصة بنا
منذ ذلك الحين ونحن نحاول
جعل القراءة مع عائلاتنا
ومن فرنسا  الزوجة من باراغواي
مما يعني أننا أسرة
في أمريكا وفي
أوروبا ليس من السهل تنظيم
قراءة مع أشخاص في كلا الجانبين من
العالم جاءت metaverse كأحد
الخيارات التي أردنا التحقيق
فيها لنا وأيضًا للأشخاص الذين  نحن
نساعد [الموسيقى] على أساس يومي ،
فنحن نريد ربط كلا الحدثين ، لذا دعنا
نقول مثل مع الواقع الافتراضي ، يجب أن تكون قادرًا
على حضور الحدث والتفاعل مع
الأشخاص أثناء تواجدك بعيدًا على المدى القصير ،
أرى حقًا أنه أصبح بديلاً
جديدًا  طريقة جديدة للانضمام إلى حدث
لا يمكنك تجربته
[موسيقى]
لك